Transcription: Pari A
Relecteur: eric vautier
Ce matin, vous vous êtes levé,
vous êtes regardé dans la glace
et vous vous êtes reconnu.
Ouf !
Je dis ouf parce que pour H. M.,
le patient de la célèbre neuropsychologue
canadienne, Brenda Milner,
les choses se sont passées
un peu différemment.
Un matin, H. M. se lève,
se regarde dans la glace
et voit un vieil homme
qu’il ne reconnaît pas.
Pourquoi ?
Mon nom est Alain Brunet.
Je fais de la recherche en neurosciences
à l’Université McGill, au Canada.
Et je vais vous parler de psychiatrie
et de neurosciences, et de mémoire.
H. M. était un grand épileptique,
et suite à une ablation
des hippocampes dans le cerveau,
H. M. ne sera plus jamais capable
d’enregistrer un seul nouveau souvenir
dans son cerveau.
En d’autres termes,
le disque dur de H. M. est HS.
De 1953, date de son opération,
jusqu’en 2008, date de son décès.
On a beaucoup appris en neurosciences,
grâce à H. M.
On a appris beaucoup de choses sur le bon
fonctionnement de la mémoire,
et sur ses dysfonctionnements.
Tenez, puisqu’on est ensemble ici,
on va vérifier le bon fonctionnement
de votre mémoire.
Alors, vous allez fermer les yeux
et vous allez penser
à votre premier chagrin d’amour.
Ça y est.
Tout vous revient, n’est-ce pas ?
Son nom, son âge, son odeur même.
Comment l’oublier ?
Linda !
Quand elle vous a laissé,
c’était la catastrophe, n’est-ce pas ?
Oui, bien sûr.
Mais maintenant,
vous avez surmonté cette épreuve.
Néanmoins, ce souvenir est
particulièrement intense,
vous ne trouvez pas ?
Oui.
Intense.
Mais en fait le problème,
le vrai problème,
ce n’est pas Linda.
Non, elle était sympa Linda.
Le problème, c’est le psychotrauma.
Chez les anciens
de l’Université de Montréal,
il y a des souvenirs qui sont
trop bien consolidés dans notre mémoire.
Ce 6 décembre 89,
quand un étudiant entre à la fac de génie
avec une arme semi-automatique
et tue quatorze étudiantes.
Au département de psycho,
nos profs se mobilisent
pour offrir de l’aide.
Mais à ce moment-là,
on ne sait pas encore très bien
comment venir en aide
aux victimes de psychotrauma.
Ça a été pour moi l’occasion
d’une profonde remise en question.
Et aussi, j’ai eu envie
de chercher des solutions.
Un jour, j’étais en stage
post-doctoral, en Californie,
et le grand Larry Cahill donne
une conférence publique.
Et il va me donner une idée
de recherche étonnante.
Vous savez pourquoi
vous vous souvenez si bien de Linda ?
Au moment où Linda vous laisse,
votre cerveau baigne littéralement
dans un bain d’hormones de stress.
Et ces hormones de stress vont
venir consolider ce souvenir,
et favoriser la création
d’un souvenir lourd, intense.
Oui.
Imaginez maintenant, un instant,
que vous ayez pu bloquer
ces hormones de stress,
les empêcher de faire leur travail.
Que serait-il arrivé
de votre souvenir de Linda ?
C’est le genre d’hypothèse
sur lequel j’ai eu envie de travailler.
Et après plusieurs années de travail,
de recherches, de publications,
je peux vous dire une chose.
Si le souvenir de Linda était encore
pour vous une source de détresse,
ici, maintenant,
et si vous suiviez mes instructions, et
qu’on réactivait votre souvenir ensemble,
tout ça combiné avec une toute
petite dose de propranolol,
un vieux bêtabloquant génériqué,
eh bien, je pourrais diminuer
la force émotionnelle de ce souvenir,
maintenant et pour de bon,
vous soulageant ainsi de votre tourment.
Cette méthode s'appelle la méthode Brunet.
Elle est disponible maintenant.
Y a-t-il des volontaires pour l’essayer ?
Je vois que vous êtes encore très attachés
à votre souvenir de Linda.
Mais ce n’est pas grave, c’est bien, même.
Ça veut dire
que vous n’avez pas besoin d’un psy.
Mais si je remplace ce souvenir par
terreur au Bataclan,
à Nice.
Au Bataclan et à Nice, on a trouvé
des centaines de personnes
pour recevoir notre thérapie.
Des centaines de volontaires.
Six séances.
Six petites séances de 25 minutes,
assorties de la prise
d’une faible dose de propranolol,
ont permis de transformer
un souvenir traumatique
en banal mauvais souvenir.
Et ça continue.
Ensuite, on est allé au Népal
après un tremblement de terre.
On est allé dans les Caraïbes, après Irma.
On est allé au Liban, après l’explosion
dans le port de Beyrouth.
On est allé en Syrie,
aider des enfants dans les camps.
Et ça continue.
A ce jour, 1200 médecins et psys
ont été formés à la méthode Brunet.
Et ça continue.
Ça continue.
On me demande parfois :
« Professeur Brunet,
mais comment se fait-il que
nos souvenirs soient si malléables ? »
Eh bien, un souvenir, selon Lewis,
c’est un peu comme un fichier
dans votre ordinateur.
Vous devez le sauvegarder
afin qu’il persiste, n’est-ce pas ?
C'est la même chose avec les souvenirs.
Vous avez la mémoire de travail RAM,
et la mémoire de sauvegarde ROM.
Pour qu’un souvenir soit sauvegardé,
le souvenir doit passer
de la RAM à la ROM.
C’est la consolidation mnésique.
Par la suite, un souvenir remémoré
va passer de la ROM à la RAM,
puis ensuite, il va être mis à jour dans
la RAM et sera reconsolidé dans la ROM.
C’est la reconsolidation.
Maintenant, si une interférence survient
au moment où le souvenir
est consolidé ou reconsolidé,
sa force émotionnelle va être diminuée.
Par contre, avec votre ordinateur,
c'est plus radical.
C’est une interférence du genre
panne de courant survient,
vous perdez tout ce qu’il y a dans la RAM,
et la ROM n’est pas mise à jour.
Un peu comme pour Monsieur H. M.
Mais le handicap de H. M.
était irréversible.
La pathologie induite
par le souvenir traumatique, elle l’est.
Maintenant en psychiatrie,
on peut envisager une médecine curative.
Pour la première fois
dans l’histoire de la psychiatrie,
on peut envisager une médecine
qui va plus loin que
vous donner un psychotrope
pour masquer vos symptômes,
au prix d’effets secondaires
souvent importants,
et le lendemain, on recommence.
Non. Maintenant, on est capable
d’aller chercher un souvenir
particulier dans votre mémoire,
comme un livre qu’on sort
de la bibliothèque,
on en diminue la force,
on remet le livre dans la bibliothèque.
C’est très pratique
pour soigner certaines pathologies.
Comme certaines phobies, par exemple.
Comme des deuils irrésolus.
Ou des psychotraumatismes,
petits et grands.
Vous vous dites peut-être :
« Ce truc, ça soulève quand même
des nouvelles questions éthiques.
Doit-on forcément
vivre avec le fardeau
de notre plus mauvais souvenir,
ou non ? »
Vous vous dites peut-être :
« Moi, je suis le portfolio
de mes souvenirs, de tous mes souvenirs,
bons et mauvais.
C’est ce qui me définit,
c’est mon identité.
Et du coup, pas touche à ma mémoire. »
Vraiment ?
Moi, dans mon bureau,
je reçois des gens qui me disent :
« Depuis mon événement traumatique,
je ne suis plus capable
d’avoir des relations intimes. »
« Depuis mon événement traumatique, je
fais des cauchemars toutes les nuits. »
« Depuis mon événement traumatique,
je ne suis même plus capable
de marcher librement dans la rue.
Comme j’aimerais retrouver
cette personne que j’étais. »
Alors, si un jour, vous aussi,
vous rencontrez votre 6 décembre.
Sachez qu’il y a maintenant
des psys et des médecins formés
à une méthode très spéciale
et qui sont là pour vous aider
à redevenir enfin celui que vous étiez.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)